they got me
twitter finally got me i was out i was
doing work i came back home and i looked
on my computer screen and there was a
thing because i had twitter open and it
said you you are being locked out of
your account unless you delete the
following tweet
this is why let me tell you why this is
crazy i was calling out grooming
and i don't
not like willy-nilly just call people
groomers like some people have been
doing so there's one story where uh well
let me pause a second we know that
twitter and reddit have announced
they'll ban the term groomer because
they say that word applies to all lgbtq
people which i have certainly argued
against quite a bit
and so i had a tweet
that was specifically showing a group of
adults showing sexual content to
children and i said yes they are
grooming your kids
twitter said i had to delete it now
i don't care about twitter like i really
don't and i mentioned this before about
jordan peters when he got suspended i
was like just delete it and then start
smacking smack talking twitter like
crazy and so i mean that's my attitude
now i'll do a show talking about it i
will use the twitter platform
to ripple out the issue as much as i can
and then uh the post millennial wrote
tim pool goes to war with twitter
because i started him i started pulling
up as many stories as i could about
twitter having defended pedophiles
numerous instances where they have done
things they've been called out for had
panic meetings and they keep doing it so
when i actually call out grooming
legitimately it wasn't like i was just
arguing with some random person i
actually had a photo of people grooming
children they deleted that i'm going to
call them out so we're going to talk all
about that we've got a couple other
stories obviously joe biden he's come
out and said there won't be a recession
it's funny because they changed the
definition of recession then biden says
there won't be one which kind of means
there probably will be one
so we've got that and we've got we got a
bunch of other stories i don't know
whatever i'm i'm all riled up about the
the twitter locking my account thing and
so we'll get in all that before we get
started though we have an awesome
sponsor it's you you guys you're
sponsoring us go to timcast.com we've
got two things shout out the house of
seven ghosts part two tales from the
inverted world if you like true crime
paranormal history murder mystery stuff
you will like tales from the inverted
world these are like hour-long episodes
and we're putting up this full season on
timecast.com exclusive for members and
we also have for those that are more
politically minded behind the scenes in
the green room with carrie lake carrie
is amazing i'm a big fan i'm so excited
when she when she says she's coming out
and coming on the show and we had a a
special green room episode with her
that's up at timcast.com right now on
the front page members only really cool
behind the scenes footage of course
we're also launching the cass castle
show really soon which is like a vamped
up expanded uh version of the show
and
no more paypal
if you are a member through paypal
you're fine you're not going to do
anything but anybody who signs up now
will be supporting parallel economy
which was co-founded by dan bongino is
also partly owned by rumble it is
censorship resistant payment processing
the reason why i got on board with them
for one i don't want to be censored and
two i want to put my money where my
mouth is and i would ask you all to do
the same stop giving your money to
people who hate you supporting us also
supports rumble because we use rumble
infrastructure it supports parallel
economy and that means if more and more
businesses start using parallel economy
and more and more customers are
processing transactions through parallel
economy then we can knock down paypal
and his other big tech silicon valley
weirdo cult people and maybe start
pushing back against the censorship and
i also have another really quick
announcement shout out to everybody who
made it possible we got massive 96 foot
billboards in times square ranging from
the totally legitimate to the totally
absurd you can see here
it says tim cast io rallies of the quote
on it is the best podcast i a 25 to 54
year old male have ever listened to with
a quote from reactor youtube star who
was of course my brother plays a
fictional character and then we got luke
ridkowski of course on the other side
parallel 20 ad sets 96 feet tall sending
a message and that message includes a 96
foot tall advertisement of mike
rooster
my rooster a very large ad of my rooster
uh and so i can tell everybody that i
bought an ad in times square with a
massive picture of my rooster
uh roberto jr and uh yeah and and then
we also have this funny quote uh the
best podcast in culture and news
everybody agrees at least that's what i
was told from me and i got to be honest
i was worried about you know people were
like hey but if you do stuff like that
it's got to be a real quote and i was
like i just said it
and like yeah but you're i was actually
told this to be completely honest i was
actually told that uh everybody thinks
it's the best and so i said we're gonna
run with it so anyway with all that
being said i'm really grateful to have a
massive 96-foot billboard in times
square of my rooster and joining us
today to talk about that and more
is the wonderful zoobee
what's up guys happy to be back thank
you for inviting me once again
absolutely who are you man for people
who may not be familiar yeah sure my
name is zubi i'm an independent rapper
author host of the real talk with zubi
podcast i also do coaching and public
speaking a lot of people know me for
different things
people know me for breaking the british
women's deadlift record several years
ago
featured on a lot of great and wonderful
podcasts including this one right here
and uh yeah all around someone who tries
to
uplift people positively who does my
best to seek the truth and speak the
truth
and keep it real and authentic and a lot
of people love me for that and some
don't right on man this is going to be a
lot of fun uh we also have mary morgan
of pop culture crisis hanging out well
hello
no mary it's scary so i'm back i co-host
pop culture crisis on youtube we talk
about movies celebrities all the
entertainment news over there it's more
light-hearted content than irl i would
say so
go over there and subscribe we also
so in all seriousness when people are
like why did you put a rooster on this
billboard it's actually a massive ad set
for all of the website which includes
mary she's got a 96 foot billboard of
herself in times square right now yeah i
kind of wish i had laser eyes in it
laser eyes yeah maybe the next we could
have done that we can switch it around
we can well it's a video we can make it
so that your eyes start glowing we can
just we just
made one yeah oh okay
i was just like can we do that though
yeah okay cool all right well we'll
we'll get that done we got we got it hi
everyone ian crossland here in
crossland.net zoopy got a book that's
hot yeah man i got two books my
children's book the candy calamity just
came out beginning of this month with
brave books you can check that out at
candycalamity.com or bravebooks.com and
of course my previous book strong advice
is available at teamzubi.com so yeah man
i had the uh first fitness book for the
grown-ups and now one for the
now one for the youth all right i'm
gonna ask you a little bit about it
later in the show yeah man we'd love to
talk about that yeah man
yeah that's uh i was enjoying reading
that kid's book so hopefully we can talk
more about it later thank you guys for
joining all right here's the first story
from the post-millennial writing about
me very quickly so i thought it was
really funny because we were pulling up
stories and i'm like what's the biggest
news of the day is it the recession that
we are in that biden's denying and then
lydia pulls up breaking breaking news
tim poole goes to war with twitter over
groomer controversy journalist tim poole
went to war with twitter on monday after
the social media platform locked him out
of his account for criticizing groomers
and i just i just went off i pulled up a
whole bunch of stories about twitter
protecting pedophiles like not
they also blocked me from posting ads i
got two emails one said your account is
locked and the other says you are now
ineligible to post advertisements on
twitter did you ever yeah yeah oh i ran
i did an ad run for the song we did will
of the people
got like three million views well and
okay like i was like wow that's actually
better than youtube so
hey maybe twitter is a good medium for
putting the stuff not anymore apparently
they said you're blocked forever you
just said my account is now ineligible
to run ads oh okay all because i had a
tweet i can't even pull it up they make
you delete it
there was an image i saw
and it showed adult men
showing
sexual things to children wow overtly
this is this was not an issue of like a
dude reading a book yeah this was an
issue of i think it was like a dude
reading a book pointing to sexual things
or something like that i honestly can't
remember but like you guys know me
people are like tim's a fence sitter why
would he do something like this there
are people on twitter who will just call
out overtly anyone as a groomer mine was
like i was making a literal point
they're like hey look at this this is
not
just some dude reading a book this is
overt grooming of children
they locked me out and told me i had to
delete it wow so i don't i don't think
twitter matters all that much to be
honest the the amount of people who saw
that tweet is in a few thousand like
tens of thousands and i was like
who cares like what's the impact on
society going to be if a bunch of people
like me on twitter see this thing i
don't care but what do i do on twitter i
you know ish post and i make the
bluetechy journalists freak out when i
post nonsense that's more valuable so
the only people who actually see stuff
on twitter are journalists and i guess
other commentators so there's no real
public value to it so i just deleted it
but here's ultimately where we get to
i'll read you a few of these stories
ev magazine twitter is a breeding ground
for the normalization of pedophilia
daily dot twitter accused of letting
pedophiles discuss their sexual
attraction to children ap twitter is not
placing sex offender notices on sex
offender accounts wow the next web
twitter lets pedophiles publicly discuss
their attraction to minors scholar
argues and then i said twitter actively
protects and supports pedophilia this is
it's just overt and outright right now
yeah and the dude the fact that they
suspended your account for what you did
is literally that
right i mean they're more upset about
you
saying hey look at what these people are
doing than the fact that people are
doing that so they are directly
protecting these individuals yep
so that's right yeah i get the vibe that
when you're in a culture war or any
conflict really if you establish
vulnerability in your foe you don't want
to have fun with it because then that
gives them a time to build up a defense
mechanism towards it so like this
groomer narrative it's very effective
because people have been grooming
children sexually we see it on you know
in videos and crazy stuff but if people
just start lol groomer groom or groomer
you start to see other people establish
an immune response and that's what the
twitter admins have done by saying you
can't even call people groomers groomers
a neutral term parents groom children to
be great people some people like
grooming is just getting someone ready
to become something and uh i think it's
insane that it's taken that people have
forced it to become this negative
connotation we should really be focusing
on the behavior and not what it's called
they decided that an actual word to
describe a behavior is a slur
imagine if someone like uh
skateboarded
and then you're like that's a
skateboarder right there and then the
skateboard was like hey man don't call
me that and then twitter was like we're
gonna ban you if you call them
skateboarders it's like they're
literally doing it have you gotten a
temporary suspension before nope this is
the first in the history of my twitter
career to ever it's almost
over your twitter career is almost over
hey man it's been a big it's been a long
run it's been 13 13 years yeah yeah i'm
on 13 as well 2009 game that's right
yeah crazy right now but you know there
was a period where i took it seriously
and i would use twitter to report the
news and post stories
now
i post a picture of a 96-foot talk
rooster that i got in times square big
beautiful rooster but with that said i
mean of course though i mean you've
built a phenomenal platform outside of
it which
99.9 of people
don't have so
in your case i mean if you didn't use
twitter again like at this stage
you're you're good to go no but the
truth is i learned this the hard way
okay um twitter was always a big mistake
how so
when i got started doing news and
commentary i was like wow twitter is
this great place i should have been on
youtube from the beginning
i should have started making youtube
videos instead i was posting on twitter
because i was convinced that people
responding and tweeting was legitimate
conversation
and then it was only like two years
later i was like i should have started a
youtube channel and i started youtube
channel and then i started building that
up and you can see
here's the thing with twitter
nobody ever walks up to me on the street
and goes you're that guy from twitter
happens to me every day does it really
yeah you you for real yeah not for me
not for me yeah yeah i've had one it was
after ferguson some guy some guy like
actually my neighbor was like hey man i
saw you on twitter but since then it's
always youtube it's always podcast it's
always someone else's show and when i
worked for these big media companies
they would outright tell you this
twitter does not drive traffic so we
don't use it and i was like what do you
mean i was all like no of course it does
like everybody's using twitter and they
were like bro and they showed me the
metrics and twitter would drive like a
tweet would get like point zero one
clicks or something just like out of the
out of the the the
maybe my analytics are like super mega
high because the difference is
if you're using twitter on twitter yeah
that makes sense if you're building a
company and trying to use twitter as
like an external tool it does nothing
for you
so being on twitter okay this is not the
case for me at all wow yeah that's not
the case that's surprising to me yeah
yeah yeah so i'm way i'm way bigger on
twitter than i am on youtube and i i put
more i spend more time on it as well
like i have a youtube channel and
instagram and facebook um but twit
twitter's the twitter's the biggest and
twitter does the most for my actual
business as well how does twitter
generate revenue for you more than you
know
i've sold tens of thousands of things on
twitter wow merchandise books
well you mean promoting them on twitter
not you're not directly selling them
on twitter you're promoting yeah there's
i mean there's a link
there's there's a link but people are
coming from twitter here's a question
twitter is the biggest sales platform
for my book for example here's the
question though yeah would you be bigger
on youtube on any other platform um well
i use instagram i do use youtube i do
use facebook i use them all do you have
your own website yeah
oh that's interesting
maybe i'm an anomaly um teamzubi.com
that's where i sell my my book my music
my merchandise but yeah for me twitter
is the biggest traffic driver do you do
videos on twitter yeah sometimes well i
will say this for me uh
there's only one thing i care about
twitter for and it's that the my
following list yeah i follow left ring
left wing right wing journalists and
news organizations and it's just a
really easy way to get a news list
that's the only thing i care about so
that's why i'm usually posting nonsense
the thing with social media is different
things are good for different people
like i know people who instagram is
their that's their generator like they
get their clients their sales their
money like they get their money from
instagram i know people where it's
facebook i know people it's twitter i
know people it's youtube um
so i think maybe just i think it just
varies from individual to individual i
think it's also what you like some
people like doing youtube and some
people just like twitter some people
like instagram and i think if you like
something then you just go that much
let's talk about the problem with
twitter and where it's going with this
story is uh this is this is part of
um
whether it's intentional or not
it was explained to me by a former trump
administration official that what the
big tech companies democrats the unit
party and yukon types are trying to do
is
give anti-establishment people just
enough voice so there's no ruckus
but reduce their voice just enough so
it's politically
uh
neutered yeah it doesn't have an impact
in the long term
so if you've got a fierce rival rivalry
between two factions and suspending one
would would result in an explosion of
rage you do is you suspend one percent
now it's a lopsided battle the left gets
a major advantage against the right and
the right slowly loses out so when you
do something like this telling someone
like me i can't say a groomer to someone
literally showing kids you know adult
materials
that's
that's that is a big move a big line
jump
so now on twitter
me getting hit me talking about it how
many people do you think are gonna fall
in line and go oh yeah it's got a
chilling effect it's the same thing they
did over the past two and a half years
they did it during the trump era and so
on it's creating that chill and um
one of the biggest issues that we have
right now in western society and it's
across the usa it's in the uk it's in
canada it's everywhere is just this
climate of fear
like the the level of self-censorship
that is now happening i mean we can sit
here and we we can you know talk talk
openly and we're all open to sharing our
opinions but
the sheer number of people hundreds of
millions of people who are just scared
to say
what they think whether they
go ahead oh no oh yeah yeah yeah no just
just the the sheer number of people who
are just absolutely terrified to say
what they think on so many various
issues from
politics to social stuff to culture
stuff to the entire pandemic situation
and
it it's it's concerning it's really
concerning especially because these are
places where you're supposed to have
free speech and if you cannot actually
exercise your freedom of speech then do
you really have it of course not and so
people seem to think
that uh well let me put it this way we
have the after hours uncensored show
over at timcast.com sign up we're gonna
have one one of those up tonight at 11
and
often
we we do say things that are like we
have conversations that twitter does
that i'm sorry that youtube doesn't
allow so we talked with marjory taylor
green about the 2020 election and what
the republicans plan to do
if uh i should say when they win in
november presumably
and uh and we talked about that
i actually don't think that conversation
would get banned on youtube i'm just not
willing to entertain that it's it's a
it's you know because youtube is their
rules are vague they're nebulous so the
issue is of course we don't want to be
censored we want to have the biggest
conversations possible with the most
people and people need to hear these
things and so it's a question of if we
have 100 topics to talk about are we
forced to take one of those topics to
the website and that's the challenge
it's it's not it's not an easy decision
to make a lot of people are like tim
sacrifice the presents on youtube stop
doing the show altogether to make a
point and i'm like then how are we
winning anything
so that's the challenge but here's what
happens people think that
we censor ourselves on this show to a
great degree not true at all there are
some things we will use innuendo for a
dance around if it is like an overt
you're like going to get us shut down
we don't call people slurs we don't
swear i don't really have any any stuff
to worry about what you need to
understand is that
we say the things we believe in
and the people who said the things they
believe in got banned right so when
people refer to me as like a milk toast
fence sitter which is like the
long-running joke yes understand that
when they start banning me
that's where the line has moved to
that's how far we're getting so it's not
that i sit here and i'm like i better
not say these things oh no i don't want
to anger youtube is that i'll outright
say youtube is dumb and says they'll
shut the show down if we say that so go
watch it on my website let's build up a
bigger website challenge all of these
systems it's the best we can do
i will say
the people who have opinions that are
overtly banned you're never going to
hear from them again they were banned on
youtube already
so
the way i described it before is that
you've got this big island and it's it's
cliffs all around that are slowly being
knocked down and eroded
and i've always been somewhat in the
middle
but then you see people on the right the
cliffs of road and they fall down as
censorship starts wiping them out
those people
held the line on their opinions
i didn't have to worry about it because
i'm like i'm not going to say the things
those guys are saying i don't agree with
them and now the cliffs have eroded to
the point where we're standing there
saying hey children shouldn't get sex
changes and they're like oh you better
watch out yeah we're going to ban you if
you say that again yeah and then it's
going to come to a point where i'm like
well i'm saying it screw you and then
they ban me so this is a good example on
twitter they said you can't call people
groomers fine i'll call them pedophiles
and i'll post all the stories i can find
where twitter protected pedophiles
because i gotta wonder about the
leadership at twitter that's enforcing
this stuff vagi i mean what's her
predilection what is she what is she
thinking about what is she interested in
that she would come to them and say i
don't want anyone to call out pedophiles
it's like i wonder why you would do that
it's really weird isn't it it's r it's
really sinister because
with stuff like stuff like this
it really should not be it shouldn't be
partisan it shouldn't be this it's not
it's not a political thing this
shouldn't be some left-right issue
regardless of where you sit on the
political spectrum during any remotely
sane time or in any remotely sane
country
everyone agrees there are certain lines
you do not cross when it comes to
children not anymore yeah and
the the fact that this is even
considered political or is becoming this
kind of i'm like dude what is
what what is going on this is it's it's
very worrying it's going to think it's
political so much as it is just them
letting go of the pretense that they're
a platform for free expression like
these platforms like twitter and youtube
used to really value
appearing
like they allow
free expression but
now they've kind of given up on that
yeah for sure i'm talking outside of
facebook and twitter though i'm talking
as a general society in a culture
right so
with these issues it's often framed as
if
this is you know you've got these these
are these right wingers are these
conservatives who have a problem with
stuff like this and
it's the cat's outside oh okay
i like it he never does this this is
weird yeah why does he want to come out
i want to drink my water i thought he
wasn't allowed in here
as long as you got your eyes on him has
he has he been grooming it up there
buddy
yeah i know what you were saying he's
been following anyway yeah i was just
saying that that it's it's nutty to me
that this has even become considered
some kind of
partisan split and i think that there's
this reactionary thing that does happen
though where if there are
you know if people on the on the left
side of the aisle are doing something
then there's a reaction from certain
people on the right to
oppose it regardless of what it is and
the opposite i think now that
people on conservatives are like wait
hang on why are you teaching my my child
about this nonsense why have you got
grown men in women's outfits reading to
children and exposing themselves or
whatever and there are there's a faction
of people on the left side of the aisle
who are like oh well conservatives have
an issue with this so i now need to
support it
let me i try to pull this story sorry uh
this is from lgbtq nation
explaining the issue they say twitter
enforces its ban on calling people
groomers as anti-lgbtq hate speech
so this is a this is like a cell phone i
mean this is them calling themselves
groomers it's the weirdest thing yeah
the point i made when they announced
this first of all the tweet i put up i
put up before they banned the word
groomer
so they're retroactively enforcing this
now
have they officially put out a policy
saying you cannot use this word i don't
know i've not seen it i've seen the
stories about it but here's here's my
here's the thing i tweeted about i said
there's a creepy guy
staring at kids and look in his lips and
say hey you you groomer you get out of
here and then a bunch of lgbtq people
walk over and go hey why are you making
fun of us and i'm like wait what that's
what's really disturbing i wasn't
talking about you guys people that
groomed children like hitler was a
groomer he groomed children to be in the
hitler youth you know um it doesn't have
anything to do with sexuality on its
face it's only when you can have people
that are sexually grooming but you can
have people that are grooming
politically grooming ideologically and
that it's getting the twitter people
twitter conflating it is very disturbing
to me yeah well that's their own
i don't know if that's a guilty
conscience or if that's bigotry on their
part because they're the ones conflaming
conflating lgbtq
[Music]
struggle with that acronym um with
grooming yeah but this is the point now
you can't call out actual pedophiles
they will suspend you if you so just
call them pedophiles i guess they said
the word groomer's a slur it's like i'm
not trying to slur you i'm trying to
call you what you are yeah i'm not i'm
not about insult i'm like i'm not going
like you're a dumb m.f er like that's
that's pointless now i really want to
know what you were quote tweeting
i don't remember um i vaguely remember
and i'm pretty sure it was a picture of
like a drag queen
showing sexual stuff to children i mean
people will find any way to defend that
and i think if we're disagreeing on
something that fundamental like you
can't show this type of thing to
children we've got like
spiritual problems to address a bunch of
left-wing publications are overtly
defending it so let me explain just for
those that haven't heard it before
uh
what grooming is and i'll preface it by
saying for those that are fans who watch
all of the episodes
not every person watches every segment
and every podcast we do and so i often
get the same questions over and over
again for example a lot of people have
said in the past like day or so like i'd
sign up for your website if you didn't
have paypal and i'm like bro we haven't
had paypal for like two weeks now so uh
i'll say this
grooming
is when you take the most base form of
uh
when we're talking about the sexual
grooming of children you take the most
innocuous element of what you want to
introduce to the kids so that no one can
say it's overt
so for instance
i knew a guy who got groomed into being
a male prostitute and how they did it
was they asked him to do a modeling
shoot for two hundred dollars a legit
true story they said the gig is we want
we're doing a lifestyle photo shoot we
want you to hang out and sit on this
couch
relax have a drink we'll take a few
photos once we're done 200 bucks cash
that's innocent isn't it it's just
he showed up wearing a hoodie and jeans
and just took some photos that was
grooming why
it's the long-term intent the next thing
they did was they said look we already
got tons of these lifestyle photos we
need like we need um like activewear and
swimwear and stuff do you want to try
wearing these shorts and a t-shirt oh
yeah no problem
then they would say sorry man if you
want the money we don't need photos of
this anymore we need you know underwear
models now he's an underwear model
that was grooming so what happens is you
take someone who's doing something adult
or sexualized introducing it to children
so a drag performance what is drag
so i was actually talking about which
time i was earlier go dancing
imagine if someone was like go go
dancing dance or story hour you'd be
like what for kids no way
they get like a woman with just like a
bra and panties sitting there reading
the kids you'd be like maybe not
appropriate hooter is probably not
appropriate for kids either
drag actually involves them taking their
clothes off for money
so when you're talking about a
sexualized
performer
just reading a book to a kid
the reason that's grooming is the goal
is to normalize the individual in drag
to a child
then when people say hey wait a minute
hold on dragon sexual i said they say
all we're doing is reading books like
exactly what they're doing now the
difference is this is
mass scale
grooming this is big tech and social
media
grooming and defending it and i'll tell
you what's really fascinating there was
a period on youtube there's a big
scandal do you remember elsagate do you
know about that is this when
people were like watching some video
maybe i'm mixing i remember there was
something on youtube where people were
watching
i don't know if it was like videos of
kids doing stuff in like swimming pools
there was something i can't i can't
explain it well there was something
on youtube yeah yeah yeah you know
i
vaguely yeah so elsa gate was when all
of these channels started making videos
of elsa the joker and spider-man running
around and the incredible hulk okay and
they were uh there was like no dialogue
and it was because little kids their
parents would turn the video on and then
it would just generate a ton of ad
revenue for the person so all of a
sudden people started making these
videos because it made money and it was
getting increasingly creepy eventually
it ended with
uh it also got to the point where elsa
was pregnant and the joker was injecting
her with things no joke okay
this turned into videos where people
literally were giving children shots
because it was generating clicks for
whatever reason the algorithm was
promoting it and then when the when the
people when people realized they could
use an ai to auto generate these videos
you ended up with videos of toddlers
drinking urine
and other overtly so this was a huge
scandal where content for children was
showing gore violence and overtly sexual
activities
youtube panicked and had to start
purging these channels and these videos
to get rid of all of it
so now the clever thing happened among
the groomers
they said
so long as you're doing these things
overtly they'll shut you down what you
need is a shield so we started to see
the lgbtp movement when pedophiles
started saying lgbtp we then saw a ted
talk from a woman who claimed that pedos
were just expressing a natural
orientation
then we saw usa today write a similar
article then we saw i think it was maybe
it was salon
and a bunch of magazines
it was a lot of times new york times i
think did it where they started saying
hey hey it's just an orientation trying
to normalize their maps
minor attracted people right and then
maps popped up on twitter yeah twitter
allows that overtly people call them out
twitter doesn't care they still allow it
now twitter will actively ban you if you
call out the pedophiles going after you
not only that there's like a huge amount
of
not safe for work content on twitter i
understand that that's part of their tos
that they allow that but they also have
a lot of accounts that openly
say in their bio that they are underage
or their age um
it's like
as low as like
13 like 12 13 14 year olds having like
these not safe for work accounts
on twitter
it's free and they allow it there's
another there's another big issue that's
happening too with um the vr chat stuff
where 13 year olds will be in these vr
chat rooms with grown adults and the
adults can it's unsupervised i mean this
is getting out of control man yeah
this is crazy i mean
this leads to a wider conversation just
about some of the some of the some of
the challenges with with technology
just in general i think
i think people often forget just how new
this all is that the smartphone and
social media combo we've only had for 15
years
we've had the internet for longer than
that but with all the
greatness and wonderful opportunities it
brings for decent people and
entrepreneurs and creatives and so on
it also opens up this pandora's box
of just completely new like what you
described with that elsagate thing yeah
i mean
that just
yeah it's so bizarre and weird it's not
something you'd think of when you're
starting youtube you're not there
thinking like oh okay this is something
we need to be careful of it wasn't just
videos of people either there were like
animated cartoons that were
made by ais that just generated whatever
got the most clicks and then that ended
up of course being like the most fw yeah
like like don't know like like i don't
drink drinking
sexual stuff violent stuff yeah like i'm
pretty into technology and i did not
know that such an ai even exists that
you can create automated animated videos
yeah using like characters from disney
and stuff so they know that kids are
going to click on it yeah it's scary and
then you bring in vr
it wasn't about clicking on it what
happens is or autoplay yup yeah yeah so
parents would give their toddlers or
babies a tablet
and then turn on nursery rhymes
and then the algorithm would just
bring those kids down a rabbit hole yo
those kids are gonna grow up and be
twisted so the parents just like come
into the room and they just see their
child watching
some wild stuff all the comments were
gibberish because the babies were just
hitting the thing randomly a lot of
people thought that some of those
gibberish comments were
uh speaking in some kind of code that
was like coordinating human trafficking
i don't know about that
maybe honestly
these things like that's the one line
for me where i mean i think any any
adult should be like this but
when it comes to people was messing with
kids in general that's just where like
dude
it's been said like why is that partisan
you know if you think about that like it
shouldn't be it should be instinctual
that's when but it's becoming partisan
have you noticed that many of these
these these people these leftists use
cartoon child avatars yes yeah yeah i
had a bunch of them after after me today
in fact they they they don't make like
they don't they don't view themselves as
adults i mean think about the word
adulting to him to imply that you're
doing something not normal yo the word
adulting implies like the actual word
means doing normal things humans do yeah
i'm adulting what is what children it's
just extended adolescence yes right and
so now you've got people who go on
twitter and they post these pictures of
themselves these fictionalized versions
it was a really funny meme a while ago
from
a particular feminist podcast
and they made this graphic of themselves
and they were all like dainty young
looking women and then someone made a
realistic version of what they actually
looked like like double chin and obese
and things like that people use the
internet to project what they wish they
were
the crazy thing is
and you probably know this better than
anybody zoobee people could just be what
they what they want to be by through
hard work right if you want to be thin
and small you just do it not everybody
can be a giraffe though and some people
want to be a giraffe and so i don't tell
you man
just pray the matrix and neural link can
take you into that reality where you can
be a giraffe but for the time yeah do
you think that maybe
some people have this kind of michael
jackson syndrome where like in their
childhood
perhaps they didn't get to play outside
and have toys and do all the things that
they
kind of wanted to and now as an adult
they're
uh trying to i i i i i don't know it's
just an idea
they're not they're not being able to
enjoy them properly i think that's
definitely screwing kids up and every
all the all the drugs but i think what's
happening is the internet and media has
created these parallel realities that
children live in
so i often think about you know how is
it that somebody wants to dress up like
a cartoon rabbit yeah like the like like
furries it's freaking weird man well i i
look do do what you want to do i got no
beef no it's not beef but it's [ __ ]
weird like we can we can say stuff is
weird i'm not saying it should be
illegal it's just weird i'm just
wondering where it comes from how is
that someone identifies as a cartoon
animal so the first thing that happened
was when i first heard about furries out
someone told me it's people who just
dress up like animals and i was like i
guess people want to be animals and then
i actually saw what they were doing and
i'm like no those are looney tunes
they're dressing up like bugs bunny with
big eyes and cartoon faces so what i
think happened was
people grew up watching
anthropomorphized animals
and a child's brain is trying to connect
itself to reality so in early human
development
human tribes the baby watches the adults
do adult stuff
and then says this is what i should be
doing and then wise itself to identify
alongside what their adults are the man
is chopping wood the woman is you know
raising the kids and gathering the men
come back with the bears and the boars
and the meat
then you do the modern era where kids
are now put in front of the car of the
tv where they watch nothing but looney
tunes
their brain says this is adult life
these are what human adults do and so
their brain creates an identity around
anthropomorphized cartoon animals then
when they're older they want to be that
i think this is why we're seeing the
explosion of identity crisis from uh you
guys know what other kin is yes i do
unfortunately
people think they're like i'm i'm an owl
wolf yeah why no no for real like
legitimate question like where does that
identity crisis come from come from but
but isn't it but we've had anthro
morphin's eyes that's one word i always
struggled anthropomorphism
anthropomorphism yeah we've had that for
that's existed for a lo for a long time
though we have american culture people
would become wolves and things like that
not the way and also
didn't we all also grow up with this and
none of us are not so so for one no we
didn't always have this okay we had the
concept of humanized or
anthropomorphized animals in like
written lit literature told to you in a
story from a person's mouth
but we had the cartoons i mean looney
tunes and all the disney stuff so
perhaps the issue is one some people are
more susceptible and two maybe some of
these people were placed in front of
these shows for extended periods of time
and their parents were less attentive on
like a mood stabilizer a lot of that's
pharmaceutical and then kids are seeing
porn average age is 11 that kids are
being exposed to porn
that's another tech thing isn't it
groomers i mean
that's another tech that's another
technology problem man i mean it's all a
tech problem yeah i mean well hold on 20
years ago i mean if you wanted to if you
wanted to access porn as a horny little
12 year old or 13 year old you could do
it but if there were the barrier was a
lot higher you'd have to get an older
person to go in and buy a magazine off
the top shelf or someone has to or
someone's got a little dvd or something
like that not just you tap a site on it
on a phone or a tablet or a computer and
just boom no verification nothing is
just there bill maher asked the question
he said why he said either we're
creating them or we're or we're what is
it creating them or shaming them why is
it that california has so many trans
kids ohio doesn't
there's clearly that's something affects
the identity of a young person as
they're growing up it's the parents
it's the parents putting out i think
it's i think it's everything it's parent
it's parents and and society of social
media is affected some of these teachers
obviously are doing this um but a lot of
parents are
it to me it's like having a vegan cat
right if you've got if you've got a
vegan cat it's it's not the cat making
the decision will die yeah that's can't
be vegan well it's not the cat making
the decisions it's like no you
you you're pushing your ideology onto
your cat if you have a trans
three-year-old and i feel gross even
saying that then that is the parents
doing that well now you've got
scientific journals saying kids can do
transit too this stuff is evil man and i
there's something really satanic going
on in the west right now man like i
can't really put it any
lighter why do you say satanic i say
satanic because i genuinely think there
are evil forces
out there and i'm talking about actual
spiritual realm
um and
to someone who is a
absolute atheist a non-believer or
thinks nothing is supernatural that
might sound weird to them but i think
that we've legit got like a demonic
issue and it makes sense that they would
go for children first yeah i i think
there's an entire inversion agenda
that's been running like very
aggressively for the people i mean
i i think there's a practical uh reason
for a lot of this we've talked about
thucydides trap on the show quite a bit
are you familiar with the concept i'm
not no explain it whenever a rising
economic power is on the verge of
supplanting the dominant power
war breaks out okay i say whenever but
it's a tendency towards so uh historians
often say
the the last uh 16 examples of an
economic power supply
supplanting the the the greater 12
instances were led to war
so the idea is why is it that i don't
know joe biden is doing these deals and
flying to china and working these deals
with china china is expected to overtake
the united states very soon yeah it was
delayed because of covid interesting
interesting about that it was delayed
because of coven and you mean the
overtake the overtake china i'm sorry
actually it might have been sped up by i
thought it would have been sped up
because china continued to grow right i
think it was sped up by it but um
think about what this means
the u.s is eroding from within you've
got the january 6 committee for instance
actively trying so eric swalwell was
asked about this he was asked about you
know isn't what he do isn't what he's
doing causing more division and he and
he said something that was like just
inane like well we have to do it or
something like that
so yeah when they lie and escalate
justice millet russia gate ukraine gate
all of that stuff just
lie-li-lai-lai-lai
they are in flaming tensions when they
go after kids and divert them or say
subvert their their development and then
cause identity crises give them drugs
destroying the next generation is going
to [ __ ] the united states
and
i have to wonder i'm not saying it's
intentional but it is fortuitous to for
those who fear thucydides trap because
the u.s is falling as fast as china's
rising
china may actually take over the world
uh the global economy with the us ever
having an opportunity to engage in war
so if you think about the council on
foreign relations i think it was they
they have their website the liberal
world order and why it was created
anybody who's arguing for the creation
of a new world order in the wake of the
liberal world order and i don't mean the
new world or conspiracy i mean quite the
the literal term a world order and a new
version of it
it would be beneficial to avoid a third
world war with china how would you do
that
destroying the economy the united states
and the upcoming generation to make to
make sure that they can't ever actually
engage in conflict there's a story i saw
recently where there's like a destroyer
that had like three captains rotate in
and out so quickly because they were
being fired and demoted the us military
can't recruit at all anymore so so
where is this coming from
no idea but i will this internal is this
external manipulation
both maybe
that's the thing i find so weird it's
like this
social and cultural
domestic
harry kyrie right like
that
it's so odd to me i mean the uk is doing
the same things many western countries
are i think the us is kind of sadly
leading the charge in this and exporting
a lot of bad ideas but
there's really a lot of people have
noticed that in the past
i want to say seven to eight years
in particular
a lot of this is re the inversion has
really really accelerated and so much of
the stuff that we talk about and all of
the
so many of these issues are things that
it would
literally as recently as a decade ago it
would have seemed completely absurd for
them to even be debates or conversations
and
there's something real really really
weird going on i do want to point out
just a quick shout out to uh joe
spinella on the super chat who mentioned
shirley you haven't seen the tanks
protecting chinese banks because china's
economy is like imploding true true
point fair point fair point uh i'm not
saying that uh china is coming out
unscathed it may be a global economic
collapse the whole system is just
imploding for whatever reason you saw
with the trans-pacific partnership in
2010 that was the first warning sign for
me barack obama signed on and it gave
there's this thing called the investor
state dispute settlement clause in the
trans-pacific partnership deal that
would have given malaysian oil
corporations the power to sue the united
states government and the taxpayers
would have to pay the bill if they
thought that americans were
discriminating against their oil
companies and didn't want to buy their
oil then they could sue us and it was
giving corporations insane power over
american citizens and obama was on it he
like he didn't know or he didn't care
and trump shut it trump shut it down
like the third day he was in office or
the second day was in office
um but that they were trying to do that
is very overtly transferring power from
the citizen-american democracy
republicanism to corporatism yeah dude
look at the last two and a half years
like seriously i mean
how of all these countries
in a very coordinated fashion i mean
it's one thing if one country goes nuts
but it's literally been
uk canada every country in western
europe pretty much except sweden usa
new zealand what what was it that world
war one you had the the three countries
they were cousins with each other was
like france who was it germany and and
who else or something like that germany
austria i don't know i don't remember um
but it was like these three leaders were
going to war with each other they were
cousins
it's like they're all related to each
other that's just that i'm not surprised
by any of that
powerful
i think we're witnessing a controlled
demolition man
you think they're intentionally
destroying the economy and
dude everything that people are freaking
out with right now with the economy
supply chains inflation
i'm not saying you're wrong it's all
completely predictable and predicted by
myself and other so-called conspiracy
theorists like well i got this stuff
started it was very predictable and and
very obvious i got evidence for you okay
so uh
i shouldn't we'll call it circumstantial
evidence and we'll call it logic okay so
uh ukraine russia war right invasion of
ukraine
fertilizer from russia not getting
exported u.s is in trouble
ukraine and russia are neither are
exporting enough wheat they can't
produce any there's a war going on they
can't produce as much
global famine you've heard them talk
about it yes yeah okay then why in
europe are they telling farmers in
ireland and the netherlands to stop
farming in the uk and the uk why are
they telling these farmers these
countries stop farming right now control
demolition but uh hold on the same
people who are telling us that there is
going to be a global famine
are also telling their farmers to stop
farming
that's very strange isn't it i mean
they're saying famine's coming you
better stop farming around so it's like
okay do you want people to like run out
of food yeah it's weird i mean the thing
is and and
it's impossible to not be a quote
unquote conspiracy theorist these days
after the past several years
if you are just interested in thinking
but they they've created this right if
people
who are in power or people in corporate
media and so on so-called public health
officials and the the experts which we
keep hearing about if they refuse to be
honest and they just continue to lie and
to gaslight and to shift gopros for
years and years and years on end like
every every single day they're just
lying to people then naturally you are
going to have people trying to work out
wait what is going on this narrative is
not making sense this is not logical
this is not rational it's not based in
science it's not based in economics
nothing
what what is going on it makes people
wonder can we stop it
i think people always ultimately have
the power we can resist the starvation
by growing local food well that's what
i'm getting to my question is if if we
are in a controlled demolition do you
think it's possible that people reverse
course and stop this yes it's always
possible i i don't think this is the
first time being here in history by
voting for trump is what you're saying
mega
yeah i mean
look i i don't think that this is the
the first or even close to the worst
thing that humanity has faced on any
level um i think it's important to
always maintain a sense of gratitude and
perspective both historically and and
geographically and i think there's a lot
of real stuff to be very very concerned
about but in terms of my optimism
i mean you look at history and man
there's
countless examples of very very dark
times where i'm sure people in certain
countries or across the just thought you
know what this is
this is a wrap this is the end like this
is a freaking a freaking nightmare and
people have always come out
on on the end of it thus thus far right
our species is still going there's more
of us than ever before
so i think one thing that people often
forget though is that history is not
finished right it never is no history
we're living through the history of the
future right i'm sure if you go back to
1910s and you talk to people in europe
or in america or whatever i'm pretty
sure they thought that they were very
advanced and they were past all the war
and the chaos and the the famine and the
genocide you know we're we're cool we're
advanced we're smart we're moral we're
decent people
and then boom world war one boom world
war ii right
that would not have been remotely
predictable
well
what's happening now
they say that there's uh overpopulation
climate change from too much pollution i
say okay they say we gotta have late
term abortions
then they gotta they say we also gotta
give drugs to children that will
sterilize them and i'm like the end
result of that is just the left
conservatives aren't engaging in that
for the most part they'll be they'll be
brought down by it to a certain degree
but not completely and so i wonder about
this the end result
the strong survive
if there's an artificial flood or a
natural flood whatever you want to call
it some some emergency be it an economic
crisis an environmental crisis or a
cultural crisis in the end the strong
survive well it's the adaptable that
survive the strong may starve it's also
the people it's the people who show up
for it the future will go to those who
show up for it
so if i'm sitting here
saying to everybody who's watching this
show and you are as well like hey it
feels like there's a collapse happening
and it may be on purpose
the best case uh the best evidence in my
opinion is that they're claiming a
global famine is coming while telling
farmers to stop farming that's
indicative of they're intentionally
trying to starve reminds me of well so
my point is if you hear that
you had two years advanced notice
watching my show if you haven't for that
long to i don't know move out of the
cities get some get get a small piece of
land where you can grow enough food for
your family or to buy emergency food and
start preparing for what may be coming
but i'll stress it again when the powers
that be screaming your face for two
years a food shortage is coming
then you actively see them shooting a
cop shot a live bullet at farmers
because they want them to stop farming
it's like okay in the netherlands in the
netherlands like they're willing to kill
these farmers to shut down their protest
yo they're telling you they are not
going to let you have food i think maybe
you should plan for that it may be like
a misdirected intention like i keep
thinking about mao's great leap forward
and the communist chinese revolution of
what was the 1960s and he moved all
these farmers off the farms and then
gave like all these people from the
cities he moved them out to the farms
like now you're in the farm but they
didn't know how to farm so a bunch of
people starved maybe it was intentional
i don't know stalin did the same yeah
you starve the the resistance and then
you have less resistance so
if they think there's an overpopulation
issue and they want a slower growth of
population
what would be a good way to do that dude
they want depletion of it and the people
who are imposing this so-called
controlled demolition are certainly
going to survive the
famine
civil unrest whatever happens and then
the so-called like strong of you know
maybe people people watching this show
who do what the things that you just
listed are also going to survive it then
what happens maga people are the future
is that it i don't i don't think
anyone's overtly said they want less
people people keep saying they want that
that's not true bill gates wrote an
article about it saying that there is
way too many poor people being born in
africa and that's what we got there's a
lot we got to slow down there's a lot of
anti-natalism and it's it's not new
anti-natalism has been running for
decades but to your point if
we're talk
your point about the strong surviving
when there's no food it's the people in
cities who suffer the people who live
out in the countryside like yo you drive
up the mountain everyone has chickens
like to them it's and people who listen
to this who live in the country know
exactly what this is better than i do
because they've been doing it their
whole lives it's like you wake up in the
morning get eggs from the chicken it's
no big deal growing up in the city you
go to the supermarket to get your
bleached eggs now if there's a food
shortage the people who have their own
chickens don't have to worry about it
y'all you're going to be eating
cockroaches and bugs and crickets i got
like 30 40 chickens out there oh you'll
be oh they're oh they're pushing the
insects hard
the chickens are going to eat the
crickets and i'm going gonna eat that's
the way to go but chickens smell and
they they're they pollute the
environment so not everyone can have
them unfortunately no no chickens when
they poop we so uh we don't do it
properly because we are still living in
this luxury what you do is uh thomas
massey man that guy's a genius he has
something called the klux capacitor
it's a solar capacitor that charges up
and then releases a charge pulling a
chicken coop about an inch so all day
the chicken's coop moves
and the chickens poop in the grass and
he said
the trail of grass behind the chicken
coop is lush and fertile oh wow because
the chickens are actively eating the
bugs in the grass and then fertilizing
the soil so it's a perfect cycle
brilliant wow what you do in the
chicken's poop we've got these big
mounds because we did construction and
it's crazy how big and tall the the wild
shrubbery and grass have grown on it
because it was just a huge pile of
chicken it is impressive
i looked up at it and saw for the first
time like it was just a little that was
wild yeah well it was it was two big
mounds of chicken crap and it's like i
think what happens is the nitrogen
escaped from it and then it's fertile
and then the plants just go nuts i'm
with you zubi i i think all you guys
actually kind of been touching on this
that that if they want a slower
population growth or less people one of
the two and they they want less carbon
in the atmosphere that they want we're
running out of food but they want the
farmers to stop farming it feels like
they want to starve a segment of the
population to propel and these people
that want it must be insulated from that
in some way i think it's because they
know that not the entire globe
can enjoy the
first world luxuries that a lot of us
enjoy
and
now they their version of preparing for
that prospect as the population grows is
to
by any means necessary deplete the
population and then hoard the resources
for themselves
and no one i don't think anyone knew
stalin was trying to kill his population
until after it happened or now until
after it happened like you don't know
when it's coming otherwise you've
stopped it you prevent it exactly yeah
people understand people also are really
bad at stopping things
they're good at running the river flows
in one direction really again um i hate
to keep referring back to the past two
and a half years we've just lived
through but i can't think of a more
blatant in your face example well of
people not stopping things when there's
a clear and simple opportunity because
tribal is i think people have a natural
tendency towards resistance we have
sports because they want to fight
against something it's also just fear
with the last two years there's such an
easy way
to resist yeah and people didn't do it
they still aren't doing it and ian makes
a good point though uh
when i was younger i used to complain
that people cared about sports more than
politics and i didn't understand why we
have these stories about you know bush
and the invasion in iraq and then you
get obama and i'm like i wish people
cared more about this than say like the
packers or whatever and now i'm
understanding exactly why that's a why
it was good that we had sports
people don't care or want to understand
they want tribal conflict and so while
they're saying i choose because no one
forces you forces you to do this they
say
i'd rather watch the baseball game and
argue with my friends about who's better
at baseball and then i say well i care a
whole lot about the conflict so i'm
going to pay attention to that it
actually works out really well that the
people who aren't smart enough or don't
want to engage in worldly affairs choose
not to so they're not voting for evil
people or being susceptible to
demagogues but once tribal once uh
politics became pop culture
now you have people being sucked into
the demagoguery of the democrats or you
know they argue donald trump but it's
the democrats that are funding trump
supported candidates while claiming
they're the apocalypse so this is what
the democrats have done they're i saw
this montage it was horrifying
where all of the cable news outlets are
talking about the january 6th hearings
as a season of shows with a season
finale
they have made it entertainment to
escalate political conflict to me like
you were saying zooby it sounds like
they're doing it on purpose to cause
political conflict i wrote for newsweek
when they when raskin included me in his
evidence that this is the goal to drive
a wedge to create escalation
let me let me just let's jump to this
next story so we can call out joe biden
we got this from the hill oh boy biden
says quote god willing i don't think
we're going to see a recession really
god willing i don't think i don't think
we'll just put dot dots after that joe
so the bind administration that was
yelling said uh well they're all coming
out and saying this a recession is
normally two consecutive periods with
negative growth talking however that's
not really what a recession is so we're
not really in a recession even if that
is the case so thursday we're going to
find out if it's an official recession
which we all know it is and that's why
they preempted this by saying
uh despite the official definition of a
recession that's not a recession and
moving forward we won't see one
okay this is trying to reduce panic
this is just like at the beginning of
covid when they were telling us not to
buy masks yeah it's all it's all about
lying because they don't believe in the
good will of
i tell people listening this
we can do what we can do we can speak up
we can try and uh
provide information to people we always
got to be calm reasonable and rational
and then when those people don't want to
listen there's only so much you can do
you can you can bring a horse to harvard
but you can't make them learn you've
however you can go to a store and buy
beans that will last you for a few years
you can stock up on emergency water
emergency food you can get out of cities
now some people tell me
yo
i can't afford to leave the city totally
get it totally understand it's not easy
i'm sorry i don't have answers for
everybody i will tell you that there may
come a time where things get so bad in
cities and i say may come a time i don't
know where you're like it is preferable
to just start walking to leave
everything behind strap on my shoes and
walk out of that city if say like the
water system fails or something like
that i'm not saying it will i'm saying
for the time being if you can't afford
to leave the city it basically means
that the way you live in the city is a
better standard for you than just being
homeless and wandering through the woods
that i understand
times may come though so do what you can
is my point yeah guys make sure you have
passports i know a lot of americans
don't have passports so if you don't
have a passport please get one but do
you know why they don't
because they never leave but you know
why they don't leave it's a big country
it's a big country
the united states is about as big as
europe is and it's quite xenophobic
people are told at least i was growing
up that the outside world is very
dangerous the outside you know outside
the united states you'll get you might
get attacked on the street and you know
there's some truth to it you go to south
america the cops are bribed you know
you've got to be careful where you walk
is more dangerous than a lot of
countries new york cities it's a jungle
so it's a mechanical jungle it's always
funny because like you guys know i grew
up in the middle east i grew up in saudi
arabia and it's very funny how people
have this idea of
that being some super dangerous place
i'm like bro it's safer than literally
everywhere in the usa let me let me tell
you the problem with these big cities um
let's say
you have a chicken and that chicken
takes a dump right in the middle of your
yard
you don't you don't think twice you
don't care yeah the rain comes a day
later that poop is long gone
what happens if two uh 20 tons of
chicken crap plopped right in the middle
of your yard it's a lot of bacteria yeah
i'm sorry rain's not going to wash that
away it's going to be months and it's
still going to be there to be festering
it's going to be that's a city yeah so
it may so i've argued with like michael
mals for instance about overpopulation
and climate change i think it's a
problem and then ultimately we come to
the agreement well population density in
cities is a problem sure agreed these
cities are bad what do we do to get
people to stop
being in cities i mean for one the
cities are struggling to maintain
themselves but also
when all of these humans when you get
like 10 million humans in one area i'll
take a dump at the same time that goes
into one place the rain and the water
can't wash it away you spread those
people out over a few hundred square
miles and now the rain can deal with
that and the earth can you know
rebalance everything what i don't get is
i'm looking at the world economic forum
website we well weforum.org i think
that's it but the world the world's mega
cities they want to build mega cities by
2030s of course they do i don't
understand this logic because if they're
if they're centralized dangerous
starvation
uh vulnerabilities why would they try
and make more of it you just explained
it
like they want to control people's views
they're not good people bro you're
you're thinking under the see this is
the problem that normal decent kind and
compassionate people have is they it's
really hard to understand
someone like willfully doing something
that is
cruel or harmful to others you can't get
your head around it because you're
always trying to think well they must
mean well and there are people who don't
there are people who don't right there
are people who do not care about human
beings and do not care about humanity
and they're not good people so you can't
view them through this lens of them
wanting to
help you
i'll give you give you a good example
adam kinzinger okay i think he's the
perfect example of
he doesn't care about people who's who's
that i'm not sure he's a republican on
the january 6 committee okay and he's
going off and off about trump and how
the republicans are bad and all that
stuff but this guy's not running for
reelection all he's doing is setting
fire to the house as he leaves
he could say look clearly this is not
for me clearly what's happening in this
country is problem i'm gonna i'm i'm out
i'm leaving right now instead he says
i'm not gonna run for the election but i
am going to inflame tensions to the most
extreme degree possible starting fires
before i go yeah there's no reason to do
that it's a real thing i mean dude you
see this on a small scale on social
media every day
right there are people on there
fortunately you know they don't have
like giant followings or a lot of
influence and power but they're purely
they're they're purely destructive right
it's purely destructive and malicious
energy there's nothing positive that
they're doing they're literally just
there trying to hurt people trying to
bully people trying to attack people and
they're doing a day in day out right now
you take someone with that type of
psychology and you actually put them in
a position of power
and influence
like what are they gonna do again we
we've we've seen this in history um and
there are people like that who exist
it's a very very tiny minute fragment of
the population but there are eight
billion people in this world perhaps so
there are millions and millions of uh
it's an emergent phenomenon that when
meritocratic individuals create a safe
and secure society it protects
individuals who normally would not
survive those people
who can't survive who use words like
adulting because they can't live on
their own without someone like better
adulting
like well you might have to fight a bear
for food one day or something these
people can't survive you end up with a
large portion of anti-meritocratic
individuals who don't make systems work
they vote against the interests of those
who do and the system flips over the
boat collapses the strong of course
climb up learn to swim and survive and
all of those weak people get
gulaged or whatever it's the adaptable
it's the ones that get capsized and
figure out how to get to shore to
rebuild society again that are the ones
that survive it and the strongest may
just go down because they don't think
quick enough they're so used to their
own
system that they've created and they're
very good at it that when the system
capsizes they don't understand right but
that's basically what it means it
doesn't mean a guy who can lift 50
pounds it literally means those who are
capable intelligent and understand are
likely to perceive threats plan ahead
effectively and survive it's a darwin
quote it's not the strongest of the
species that will survive but the ones
that are most adaptable to change right
so basically
that's the general concept when
when a crisis is happening who's most
adaptable to change well first and
foremost the people paying attention who
are watching it come and that aren't
connected to any one ideology let's say
there's a bunch of people in a tribe on
an island and half of them have been
noticing something weird happening on
the shoreline they're paying attention
and the other people are like we don't
care we don't care nothing's going to
happen well the people who are who
notice the change are the ones who are
more adaptable and then they go we're
going to go climb that hill real quick
and then the tsunami comes and everyone
else gets wiped away yeah people that
are like god will save me like get that
out of your mind right now you save
yourself
perhaps
i mean i disagree with that framing of
it no one at least i hope no one thinks
that like
i don't know if they're on the street
and they get mugged that jesus is going
to come save them from getting mugged
i don't think they think that they're
talking about their spiritual
you can't just like it's not their
physical
i i know it's it's comforting to think
that there's a being that's protecting
you but it's not you got to protect
yourself in this harsh reality
i mean they're talking about spiritual
protection right not
like famine won't happen because jesus
will save us from famine like that's not
that's not gonna not happen i can't i
don't know no one thinks no one no one
thinks like that i hope i hope so no
it's the harsh ideology that's the so
suffering is like the cornerstone of
like the christian faith so buddhism too
some people some people certainly
believe it there are people who believe
that god is a man in the clouds like
sitting there watching everybody that's
just one ideology don't think the
government's gonna save you don't think
god's gonna save you don't think your
neighbor's gonna save you like you have
to protect yourself and your interests
what's the saying god helps those who
help themselves yeah that's true there's
another saying uh chance favors the
prepared
and call it any way you want it if you
are not doing what you have to do to be
prepared for what might be happening
well then like what's gonna happen like
i think look having ha i think to you
know
options are always good
and i think that
something that people should really know
by now is to
just just have options right have
options in terms of places you can live
ways you can earn money things you can
do don't be so
i don't know like
maybe because of how i've grown up and
the fact that i travel so much
i've got i know i have a different view
than most people but i think that we
were talking about the big cities and i
think that something that really happens
of course is just inertia
right like it's hard to if you're used
to a place especially if you've grown up
somewhere
and you live there and your friends and
families are there and it's what you
know
it's hard to
up and move i understand that it can be
difficult emotionally it can be fine
financially you might have a job or a
career like there it's i'm not saying
that it's just super duper easy for
everybody but i think that seeing where
just the level of uncertainty in so much
of this stuff
it is wise
to
just bear that in mind and take take
steps don't just sit there and say oh
you know the the end is coming the end
it's like okay take take some steps if
you haven't already been doing it over
the past few years take some steps so
that if stuff does hit the fan or you
are getting very uncomfortable or
whatever it is you've you've got options
having options is always wise let me let
me pull up this story from fox4
new proposal would give id cards to
illegal immigrants could be used for air
travel so i decided to uh
research some basic definitions
do you know what a country is defined as
anybody know what a country is defined
as
a country yes
um how do you define the word country i
can give what i think is a definition it
might not match up exactly let's hear it
um i would say
an
area or region
with a
some degree of juris jurisdiction
over it
and
board has to have a border who the
region has jurisdiction it's like a rock
monster owns the land that it is well i
would yeah i would say okay a a piece of
land or a region with a border it's got
some geographical and you need one more
component capacity
and then
some type of governance structure people
people a country is defined as a nation
with set borders
okay and a nation is a group of people
with a shared history and set of laws
history culture or set of laws okay so
when you combine that you have nation
and country they're not the same thing
the united states is a country okay it
is a nation with borders
so when we have a wave of a million plus
illegal immigrants entering the country
then you have no country if the borders
can't be enforced so the latin for
country is against or opposite
and then the other part of it from the
medieval latin is against a lying
opposite land so you're literally in
opposition to the other land that is
close to you so when you have a million
people under the borders and there's
nothing being done about it when you
have the government facilitating the
trafficking of children which the
binding administration has been doing in
the dead of night secretly
there's no borders no you have no
country now about that nation yes a
shared history well you don't have a
shared history with people coming from
other nations entering in violation of
your laws so there's no shared history
and there's no shared laws and there's
no shared culture there is no nation
there is no country
giving id cards to illegal immigrants
that could be used for air travel
this is just creating
open citizenship
why do you think they're doing this
again this is destroying the united
states yeah exactly exactly this is true
to me this is the controlled demolition
again because it's like well
why why why would you do that let me let
me let me let me simplify real quick
yeah uh for you for everybody at home
zooby let's say you have a big um
granary let's say you have a big storage
facility full of food and your guards
open the doors and say everybody come on
in and you're like but that's where i
keep all my stuff and they're like bigot
yeah so uh
look this country is wealthy but you
can't just have an endless flow of
people coming in
even bernie sanders said the exact same
thing at a rally in 2015 he said you
know heavens
if we open the borders we'd be flooded
by the world's poor we can't do that
yeah back wouldn't bernie cared about
the working class i guess
i think that people believe
uh that the avalanche only flows one
direction and so they're just getting on
board they're trying to surf the wave
they're like nationalism is done
globalism is now one earthen country and
let's just do it and it's not possible
yeah it doesn't seem it's going to be
abrupt and a lot of people will get hurt
in the process but like no it's just a
world government duh people will
definitely seem to want that we are
going to call it the liberal
international economy by the way that's
lie for from here on out yeah that i
love this yes the lie so um when you go
to egypt for instance yeah you're
egyptians aren't allowed to gamble or
eat pork like by government law yeah so
how are we supposed to have a one-world
government when it's like we're going to
get a big shipment of pork in for our
bacon and then a bunch of other
countries are like no no no no our tax
dollars can't go to that you're not
allowed to do that
this is essentially what they're trying
to do making entertainment into
something global yeah it doesn't work
you know what global entertainment is
not even a common language like you
can't even communicate properly with
most people in the world let me let me
tell you guys there's a you ever see the
just for laugh gags no oh i think so
they're like those youtube videos where
there's one where it's really funny a
little girl she has four buckets ones
two of them are full complete with
change then two of them have a false top
with change on top
and so she walks over or she has she
like waves someone over
and then she asks them for help caring
she grabs the fake light buckets it's
like a little girl and she carries them
and the other people try to lift the
heavy things full of change they can't
do it they're like like how is this
little girl carrying this there's no
dialogue at all just music this was
entertainment made for a global audience
not a word being said
so when you want to create global
entertainment no dialogue that's how the
trailer for avatar was the second avatar
movie all just like
b-roll of cgi oceans and aliens and
jungles and like
ambient music and i'm like what am i
watching right now what is the story
there's none
i mean no i think it will happen just
not you think it will happen i think
it's an inevitability i think it's
impossible to avoid how so why do you
think that so technological advancement
the rapid rapid communications
development is going to result in a
global shared culture just not anytime
soon
um as soon as
by soon i mean like five to ten years
but you give it a couple generations
especially with uh
if we have air travel then i think
it's possible to have one world
government through cultural expansion
but they're also shutting down uh
air travel but they're also creating
metaverse and virtual reality
so already i used to play video games
with people in
oceania and china and japan like world
of warcraft for instance
those people are friends
they have cultural bonds stronger than
their next door neighbors
that's the kind of thing that
precipitates one world government that's
right i don't think most people are
going to have any remote interest in
that
it's it's not about whether or not
what is
i don't think you're not going to get
majority of the world onto vr and the
metaverse and all that i don't think
it's i don't think so i i think you will
i don't know if it'll be the iteration
that we're seeing now but bro we're
already there you live on twitter that's
your virtual person i'm not normal
like you'll get some people you there's
eight billion plus people in this world
and most people live in lives nothing
like what and what what did mark
zuckerberg google and starlink what have
they been and elon musk what have they
been trying to do over the past 10 years
they're trying to connect people in
various ways
they had project loon where they were
like can we get internet to you know
like the middle of africa with giant
balloons floating in the stratosphere
broadcasting we've got low orbit
satellite technology they know they need
to wire all of these people that's what
i'm saying once you get everybody on the
internet and there's such luxury that
comes with being online such advantage
that's what precipitates the expansion i
think you'll get everyone on the
internet i don't think you can get
everyone running around in headsets or
sitting there well that's that's like
saying i can't imagine everyone's going
to put a vinyl record player in their
home or like it's joe biden saying i
think i think these are really different
i think they're quite different when we
get to the point where your neurolink
implant is put in at birth and you have
a say in the matter yeah we'll get there
what makes you
why be so pessimistic in that i assume
you think this is a bad thing it's not
pessimism do you think do you think
that's a bad thing
uh i think it's it's a neutral thing i
think people uh
yeah i think it's a relatively neutral
thing i think technology is not good or
bad i do i do i do think it leans toward
the bad because we know corrupt people
will exploit all of this for for
personal gain and we could potentially
end up in an equilibrium type future
where everyone has their emotions and
thoughts suppressed and the global
leaders live freely and enjoy the perks
of being human yeah but but ultimately
look
look what twitter has done look what
facebook and youtube have become the
rapid expansion of social media in only
10 years people are going online and
they're already existing with a digital
version of themselves and it's only
expanded more and more maybe mark
zuckerberg's mark zuckerberg's legless
metaverse is not going to be the version
of wire that everyone gets into
but already
aoc for instance is not representing new
york's 14 she's representing progressive
twitter sure she gets money because one
person in every city
may have a fringe world view but
together online they make up a massive
powerful economic block they support
someone like aoc and then she wins her
ideas are unpopular and wouldn't have
won
but because
all of the weird fringe far left people
were able to raise money online
so that created something that exists
outside of a nation i saw this back
going to 2010 and we've seen it
further look at ukraine look at look at
warfare over the past 10 years when you
have individual actors joining nation
states in conflict when hackers in the
united states were aiding in the
revolutions in north africa and the
middle east this is this is global
government when you have u.s citizens
teaming up with a whole with a network
of citizens and then going and fighting
in ukraine this is global government it
is the precursor it's coming i don't
think so
i think we'll see we need one why don't
we need it but one language you
mentioned earlier not everybody speaks
one language i thought english close to
it it would be english just because of
capitalism and the way corporatism and
is putting mcdonald's all over the place
and people watch hollywood movies i
thought for sure the whole world will be
speaking english it'll be considered
like common in dnd but i don't know if
that's the case now
i don't know
we need to get internet to everybody and
fresh water to everybody and then why in
order for global internet away
i kind of do because i think the other
uh option is self-destruction if we
don't connect we're gonna destroy we'll
fight unless we're together
unified is the internet togetherness you
don't need it's a form of in any way
sure like what we're doing right now
there's like 50 000 people watching live
or something like that it's intense
unity i disagree that that's a community
though yeah not everyone needs to be
unified for for there not to be
uh severe conflict you can't unify
everybody like people are just too
freaking different but not necessarily
like we all have to do the same thing
but that we all have some sort of common
purpose or ideal i mean we do as human
beings i mean i think that's always
existed um but past a certain level um
people people are are too different and
people have such different interests and
you you travel around the world to go to
different countries
they're not all
people need conflict yeah yeah and
they're not all joining them they don't
need it it's hard enough
it's hard enough to reunite conflict
resolution it's hard to unite the usa
let alone the world one one one proposed
hypothesis i'm not a uh uh an
evolutionary biologist psychologist or
anthropo uh um anthropologist but why is
it that europe
had advanced more than the americas why
did the native american
populations man did they go on nitro
when they
started coffee into their proximity
the the european tribes were roman roads
they were boxed in a peninsula with with
very little uh room to flee to
so when resources would become strained
they'd kill each other to survive
causing a a tit-for-tat expansion of
technologies in order to survive in the
americas it was so vast the tribes would
just leave
so if you look at animals for instance
badgers why are they so vicious
they're burrowing animals they have one
dimension when they're confronted with
an attacker at the front of their of
their burrow they can either fight or
they can die so of course natural
selection
predicted that they'd be vicious birds
why don't birds attack you why do they
run away because they have multiple
dimensions they have three dimensions
you go up and leave so they're much less
likely to to require conflict more
likely to survive if you escape the
battle
in europe you had humans know where to
escape to it's a peninsula
so in these in certain parts it's like
fight or don't in this in the americas
it's like yo i got everywhere else to be
so i'm not going to fight you if i don't
have to
when when two different groups of people
are fighting next to each other for a
long period of time they're constantly
one-upping each other it's it's an
artificial uh evolutionary conflict
happening technologically
so
if humans today
stopped fighting
and there was no conflict what would
they do
play video games all day not much watch
porn all day and this is what we're
starting to see there's no conflict so
what do people do it's wall-e
get fat sit in their lounge chairs and
complain and just want free stuff to be
pleasured and gratified
that's what happens yeah one thing i've
been thinking about a lot recently
especially um
when it comes to you know children now
or the next generation and so on is
you know i think every everyone
understands and realizes that as human
beings as individuals and even as a
wider society
you need conflict and struggle
and hardship in order to
develop a
resilience right develop grit resilience
a stronger personality ability to
withstand stuff
um
and i think so many of the problems that
we have right now when we're dealing
with in the west is tim's alluded to
already is just
just people are weak people are fragile
emotionally oh my gosh you misgendered
me like like the whole world it's all
based in weakness it's based in
victimology you know nerf the world
instead of making yourself stronger
that's really been the attitude for
quite a while now and i often wonder how
is that if there is a way maybe the
answer is no but is there a way to
rather
without having
taking people through this certain grind
of hardship is there a way to
consistently
say raise
strong
minded and even physically strong
children
without
you know who aren't just going to grow
up to be these these lame snowflakes or
whatever you want to call them
without having to go through necessarily
all the same nonsense that their parents
or ancestors did there's a viral pose
it's hilarious where someone some antifa
person is like you better believe the
right is arming up and training and you
better be as equally trained and armed
as they are for the coming conflict and
what do you think the left's response
was to that
uh when we say the left who we leftists
etc
um what was their response to someone on
the left saying you need to start
training and get ready for a conflict
with the right you can't tell me what to
do no i don't know
some of us
aren't physically capable your tweet is
abe is ableist
and then they apologize saying we
understand that not everyone is able to
physically train and there are other
ways
a lot of them just ended up saying man
i'm just so depressed
was this on twitter yep one guy was like
yo i'm depressed just use me as a human
shield oh wow
you know what i know why they're
depressed too yeah jordan peterson man
he killed it he he's he's
well the the the the depression he's
killing it you know he's saving young
people in general if they just listen to
him yo people are depressed because they
have no purpose
they have no drive no no no no internal
conflict no responsibility they're just
sitting around staying at the tv like
what for yeah yeah you you have to i
mean one thing i know for for my myself
right because i'm not even gonna i'm not
sitting here pretending oh i came from
some rough background or whatever like
i'm blessed like i'm super privileged in
many regards
but i i've had i've created my own
hardship in many ways right like there
are ways that
you know in terms of your whether it's
your career or i mean what it what even
is going to the gym going to the gym is
going and
artificially
artificially creating resistance whether
to to build your lung capacity or
improve your cardiovascular system or
increase your muscles like our ancestors
would be like what on earth
are what what's what's everyone in this
room doing why don't you just do your
farm work or do your work
i was talking about this recently we had
uh uh we
purchased like
wild caught salmon or whatever yeah and
i was like so people in the us who have
money can order fresh fish
lower to middle class people get garbage
farm fish and then third world poor
people eat fresh fish
and so the funny thing is like we have a
lake out here you're allowed to fish but
you got to throw the fish back okay and
i was like that's the stupidest thing
i've ever heard not not i understand we
got to throw the fish back i'm just like
why go fishing for no reason it's like
people like simulating survival exactly
dude that's what it all is why are
people so drawn to sport yeah right like
so many of the things that we do when we
find impressive it's like
you're
making your life harder than it needs to
be you're you're creating the artificial
um pressures and why are so many people
now getting into mma and combat sports
and stuff like that's because
you need to
you're not going to get it in your
day-to-day life right you don't need to
do anything i say we do away with war we
place it we we replace it with the
sporting event
soccer maybe i don't know
football have the olympia football or
soccer yeah well that'll be whoever wins
gets to name it so it certainly helps i
also by the way i think this is part of
why why so many people snapped in 2020
because all the usual outlets
for for for energy and and tension and
even just the the social
it was just allowed to pile up
zooby where is everybody
where's everybody so we got a pilot
shortage right
we have like medical worker shortages
we've got it we've got labor shortages
across the board and they fire a bunch
of people last year but how do people
just stop working where does that food
come from
um food is very easy to acquire
but oh oh sorry you mean if these people
stop working how are they paying their
rent
um well they sorry wait let let's okay
so
why not rewind this okay airlines are
shutting down thousands of flights okay
i wasn't always aware of that yeah pilot
shortage is this specifically in the usa
uh all over i think it's all over the
world okay i mean it's heavily in the us
i follow us news but uh pilot shortage
and i'm like where did those pilots go
did they just stop working and if they
did how are they paying their bills how
are they buying food but it's not just
that you go to fast food restaurants and
they've got signs in the door saying
like we're understaffed i've seen that
every uh all over the place we went out
on memorial day weekend not
nobody
i'm like where where are the people at
where'd they all go
where are the workers how is it that
people stopped working
and didn't start working again i don't
understand like you're a pilot you
weren't gonna do go be a mailman why
would you do that you're a pilot
i don't know i'm not i'm not familiar
with the pilot thing at all generally
speaking yeah how is there a shortage of
these jobs
are they just choosing not to hire them
back or something but where is everybody
else how has the people stopped working
and they're not working now where's
their food coming from where where
they're how they paying utilities how
they paying rent or mortgages
i don't know i'm not i'm not super
familiar with this issue so i don't i
don't really know what's been happening
i'm concerned that there's a black
market evolving that people don't know
about and i'm really concerned that
people great amazing humans that got
screwed over by the last two years worth
of mandates and whatever running out of
money are going to turn to nefarious
things to get by like
human trafficking and things like that
i
man
i i'd i'd be cautious of predicting
something that dark yeah i just want to
get it on the table now so in 10 years
you guys remember i said it first i did
to put nothing past anyone in desperate
times
i made the joke to uh sheamus that the
rapture happened
and then he was like well certainly it
couldn't have you know because he's
devout catholic so it's like hey wait a
minute you know what are you saying
but uh no man look we
i mean obviously i see people out doing
stuff we wouldn't played pool the other
day and had wings good fun a lot of
people out there playing pool on a
weekend
but
when you hear about all these labor
shortages and when i go to
uh like a like a chipotle and they're
like we're understaffed please bear with
us i'm like how is it possible that
people just aren't working there there
is a lot of laziness as well and again
inertia i get it but like how do they
how are they getting by but hasn't this
always been a question i mean there are
lots of there's millions and millions
and millions of people who don't work
and haven't been working for
a long time and they somehow get but i
don't know if it's just welfare or if
it's i don't even know what all the
schemes and stuff like that are
um i just work you know we just work but
there are millions of people in this
country in any country who don't work
but they're alive
yeah i suppose i don't know exactly what
they do have we expanded the welfare
state to such a point that we can have
labor shortages and keep giving them
money maybe i i honestly have no idea
what the welfare structure
looks like here how much more money is
being spent now than was
two or three years ago
i have no idea what any of that looks
like so they say that the poor people in
the u.s rival some of the richer people
in europe because our welfare system is
increasing
deep there's a lot of layers to it
so i think that might be where they're
all going i think that over the course
of the pandemic they realized oh my gosh
i don't really have to work i'm not
essential right i can work from home
people have pointed out retirement but
that doesn't explain fast food
restaurants that doesn't explain yogurt
shops and burger burger joints i know
retirement is one of the ones for pilots
because i did see something saying that
they're not training up enough new
pilots they're raising the age
oh really wow yeah so quit yeah so there
aren't there aren't enough people being
incentivized to become pilots to
compensate for the older ones
what bothers me the us government
printed all that money in the last two
years and then just started handing it
out to people you're making you're
sending people towards bankruptcy and
then they're going to stop paying their
taxes because they can't afford to
survive you fools and then if they're
not then you're gonna have a revolution
on your hands
like the the usa maybe the usa such as
it's such a fascinating country because
one thing that americans always always
forget is how how young this country is
i always say that the usa is a teenager
as far as countries go and also it's
it's a giant teenager with 50
states it's an angry teenager
with a desert eagle yeah
like there's so many things that are
unique about the usa that make it
genuinely impossible to
properly compare to
any other country in the world it's got
so many things that are absolutely
unique i mean even if someone said oh
let's well let's compare it to all of
europe
it's like that's
maybe that's a better comparison than to
one country in europe well but it's also
it's it's so
so different abusive father you know
king george just beat the hell out of
him
i got this angry rage from our childhood
yeah we we had to emancipate ourselves
yeah we had to run away from home like
at age 12 it was crazy sibling is still
up there
acting all wacky and elitist
i love it the left has this meme where
they're like the united states canada
must feel like they've got like a
dysfunctional sibling who's you know
walking around with guns and i'm like
who's the size of a toddler maybe
i kind of think it's like you know
canada is the snooty frail you know
sibling who is the aunt karen canada
didn't run away from home like america
did no but we were the children of of
you know the crown and so canada was
like why are you fighting just do what
father says
and we were like no ch yeah
honestly every time i look at a map or a
globe i'm always like like i look at the
the geographical size of the uk or great
britain even which is even smaller and
i'm just like
how how
physics it's like the size of new jersey
isaac newton isaac newton developed
physics so england got the cannons first
and then they could hit long range with
their boats so they dominated the world
yeah they conquered india yeah i know i
i know how it happens i just look at the
size of the country it's amazing what
technology can do for a small cut like a
piece of tech that nuclear power is kind
of like that nuclear weaponry like
israel is heavily armed right now
they're massively influential on the
world stage well we give them money so
they can build weapons
yes
there you go
the federal reserve prince money i'm
british but i'm assuming the the british
also contribute exactly we put a bunch
of money into uh iraq and afghanistan
sudan and um
sudan a ton of u.s dollars goes into
people there's a map showing you all the
spending and it's funny because you get
these like certain countries that get
all of the attention like in the middle
east or israel and then you're like have
you taken a look at central america and
africa man cause
we put way more into some of these
african countries in these conflicts why
sudan
it may not be sudan anymore this was
years ago but uh
like i don't did we just deploy troops
to sudan recently believe so one of
those conflicts yeah i i it's so hard
so hard to keep track of even what's
i mean i i i totally understand why some
people just check out of politics
completely and are like yep no oh my
gosh i tried to read a bill that the
language is intentionally obvious
it's
it's so boring to read you've got to
like get into that state of weirdly yeah
and thus we have decreed that
act one
colon section cb3c2413
uh and you're like what in the hell are
you doing instead of writing a bill that
says here's what the bill does it will
say the language of this bill is changed
to read in in section 2a3 quote and will
include end quote to be in place of
section 491 quote ar 15 quote and you're
like
not with standing here two four other
bills and then replace words to
understand what your what your bill does
and they don't give you the other bill
with the bill that's intentional and
then they slip a little like and a
hundred thousand troops will be sent to
sudan but they say it in a little weird
way and like page 72
subsection three and then name the bill
something nice that nobody can disagree
yeah i wish joe biden would just come
out and just be as overt as trump was
sometimes you know because trump was
like we're going to be selling weapons
to saudi arabia it's great it's going to
be great for our economy
the entirety of the anti-war left was
just like he just
he just said
he just came out and said it they were
like
do you guys remember that meme
where trump tweeted something and this
journalist goes i have been
investigating this story for a year for
a year i've dedicated my career to
finding out what was going on this
meeting
and he just tweeted it out
he just said it it's like all my work
that's trump yeah that's so biden if he
came out and he was like look listen
here
champ
we're gonna open the borders destroy
this country
send your kids overseas to die that way
chyna wins come on
yeah right i'm like all right well there
it is on the table we're about to hit up
some super chats but i wanted to ask you
about your book because we have yeah
i've talked about it much this is a
children's book that you just
created what's the what's the plot sure
so the plot is um so i think it's
important to say so it's a collaboration
with brave books and they're a company
based in
texas that put out a new children's book
every month they work with a range of
different authors and influencers on
this so i wanted to do one that was a
lot of their books are more conservative
leaning more politically charged but
for
the uh for for a young audience but i
wanted to do one that's totally
apolitical i'd written a fitness book
before i'm very passionate about health
and fitness and taking care of your body
and oddly there aren't that many books
aimed at the younger demographic on that
topic so i was like you know what let me
do something that's completely
apolitical um
childhood obesity
is rising everywhere adulthood obesity
continues to rise and we need to talk
about health and fitness and why this is
important so
the story is about a group of friends
they're animal characters and i won't
give away the complete plot but um
they're out they're out in the desert
and
there is an incident where some pirates
come and they they raid them and they're
not they're not in good enough shape
essentially to to chase them off and to
to fight them away so they're there they
retreat back and they're just there
eating all their candy and like lazing
around and then eventually one of them
is like look guys we
you know that was our bad we need to get
in shape and so they go and they train
and they they get jacked and then the
next time the uh the bad guys come they
manage to chase them away and get well
that's that's basically the full plot
right there it's the plot this is the
plot but it's uh yeah it's more fun and
it and i made it all rhyme as a rapper i
had to make sure that my children's book
would rhyme all right let's go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel and share the show if
you really do like it post that url
everywhere head over to timcast.com
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show going up at about 11 p.m
tonight we also have the green room with
carrie lake which is up so if you're a
big fan of her and we definitely are you
can watch that as well as tales from the
inverted world i believe it's episode
fours is officially up and uh we're
doing a lot of stuff big announcements
to come soon but let's read some super
chats caleb w says sitting in a hospital
awaiting the birth of my second son what
a great way to celebrate maga month with
zubi hey kids are the best you're here
mr slytrip says do you think every
governor descends included whom shut
down a church for a day
violated the first paragraph of the
first amendment by making a pseudo law
against establishments of religion and
or our right to peaceably assemble of
course that was a violation of the
constitution
that's it i don't know what else
all right gadsden says tim poole is ben
shapiro if you gave him a skateboard
when he was a kid instead of a violin
yes
i was actually given a drum kit when i
was like seven so i and then a guitar
when i was like 12. so
maybe but ben shapiro had a really funny
joke i went when we had the daily wire i
was playing mario kart with him
and uh i was destroying
michael knowles i think it was knowles
shapiro and maybe matt walsh pretty sure
it was my watch and we were playing
mario kart 64. and i just mop the floor
with them because i i'm you know good at
mario kart right so i did the wall jump
in wario stadium cut the course in half
michael knowles was flabbergasted didn't
understand how he was in first place and
then i missed the jump a couple times
and all of a sudden i just jump and boom
i'm at the end of the level in first
place ben shapiro was just like
yeah i spent most of my childhood
studying and then going to law school i
wasn't playing video games and then he
was like he said a funny joke he was
like ladies and gentlemen here's tim
poole he spent his his childhood playing
video games and skateboarding while i
went to law school he makes the same
amount of money as me
i was like i don't have any funny jokes
but i can beat you at mario kart
all right raymond g maga stanley jr says
i love the tim pool trump quote the
bestest best
yeah we're trying to figure out like
what to put on the times square
billboards and so we had two joke ones
uh my brother whose character is reactor
said the best podcast i a 25 to 54 year
old male has ever listened to and then
mine was it's the best podcast everybody
agrees at least that's what i was told
i literally was told that though it is
true
we i can't remember who it was i came on
the show a couple people have said like
everybody says is like the best show man
i think bannon said that
something like that yeah he thought your
producer was really great too he did
just say it
yeah maybe we should have ben and back
now yeah they're going after him
all right gracefang says let those of us
using paypal to transfer payment methods
without having to cancel also twitter
actively protects and supports
pedophilia tim poole i mean but um
that's a statement of fact there there's
numerous news stories talking about them
doing it yeah i was i was like okay you
want to play these games with me twitter
i'll call out these news stories i do
uh for those of you that use paypal
on the website
i think most of you don't have to do
anything if you signed up with paypal
uh for a membership on the website
eventually it'll just automatically
process through parallel economy and you
don't gotta do anything if you used a
paypal account to do it then i don't
know for sure so
um but i will stress this again to tell
your friends we have been working really
hard to get paypal off the site as our
payment processor and to use parallel
economy so we can support new technology
from companies that don't hate you or at
the very least
like you a little bit better than
nothing right
all right let's see
uh
azalea primrose says is mary one of the
ghosts of the civil war that followed
shane back to work i know if a ghost
followed me home i would be speechless
by michael oh wow and let's not forget
about hong kong chickens
all right very good bravo bravo well
mary uh i might be he's not doing a good
job of finding me
he's looking around like where are the
ghosts
sitting here on the show apparently
all right let's see
rommel says hey guys my dog personally
wanted to thank y'all for the new camera
locations in chicken city he said he
very much enjoys watching for coyotes
and the new cameras let him clear the
perimeter much better here's 20 bones
appreciate it great yeah uh chicken city
has some major improvements roberto jr
the is the superstar he's up on a 96
foot billboard in times square i'm very
very happy and proud of that
chance jones says tim did you see lauren
southern's recap video of the whole
truth she gave you a pretty good shout
out i did not see it i'm glad to hear
though uh lauren's really cool i think
she's great and she's gonna come hang
out soon that's correct so super excited
i was wondering i know people were
mentioning she put out a video about
like the truth about behind the scenes
and how fake people were and i was like
i wonder what she'd say about me but um
i think lauren's very legit
all right let's see what we got here
more super chutes
ben andering says hey tim i want to help
you set up your coffee game shop i sent
an email to your info email and sent you
a letter in the mail i want to help
fight the culture war um
the first thing we're doing is
we are trying to find a venue
and that's rather difficult but um
we've got some during the west virginia
area we're looking at one in martinsburg
we're looking at some in charlestown we
got to figure out how we're going to do
it and then you know the idea is these
these towns in west virginia they have
like 30 to 40 000 people and they're
very small but if you build it they will
come at least that's what i've been told
you were right
so that's what we're going to do we're
going to create spaces and get everyone
to want to come out here get away from
the cities that's the plan man
aiden chavez says you guys should get
mike glover from field craft survival on
he said he was willing to go on love the
show and the guests you have on zooby
rocks zooby does indeed rock we'll take
a look at this uh who is it mike glover
i'm familiar
spencer
hermanette says the minute tim cast
launches a mobile app i will be ending
my youtube premium subscription and
becoming a tim cast member
we're working on it
yo it's very difficult and expensive to
do all this dev work but we're working
on it and you know the thing is like i
know once we have a mobile app like we
get more members which means more money
which means we can build faster and we
are we're doing we're going as fast as
we can i suppose but we're on it
maybe
integrate parallel economy into the app
well no it is it is so the the default
method of payment on timecast.com is
parallel economy
that means
signing up at timcast.com supports a
down geno company
it opposes censorship and it supports us
for the most it supports us more than
anybody but
you just you got to get more companies
using parallel economy because i would i
would be very happy if one day i was
like paypal you still use that no we use
parallel economy i've never seen what
they did to eric july i did paypal
they've frozen
over a million
verse money yeah 1.3 million no yeah not
all of it because some of it was done
like some people paid directly on his
website but there was like 1.2 million
frozen right now that he doesn't have
accuracy
you gotta get on parallel economy can
the pair can somebody else well it's too
late now right no it's never time no
it's never too late well it's too late
for the people who paid maybe their
money the money's there being seized by
frozen no
there's no reason to keep using them of
course
look i got to be honest parallel economy
is new it took us time to build like to
build the infrastructure around using
their service but it is it is been
really great i got to be honest their
website for like tracking is way better
than paypal paypal is getting by on
market dominance and they haven't
updated in a long time at least that's
the way it seems so yo eric that's bs
man we gotta hit up eric man have him
back on the show and talk about that and
on pop culture and on pop culture we
talked about it today actually and we
need to get the parallel economy guys to
just
mock 10 to getting eric set up with a
better payment system
paralleleconomy.com sign up you can
apply i'm actually in the process of
doing it right now
that's crazy man
all right we'll read some more maybe
we'll come back to that the pyromaniac
says madison hawthorne has introduced
h.r 8399 it will partially or fully
repeal the nfa hey you love to see it um
madison lost his primary though didn't
he i don't know i think so
yeah
so but um i'm glad someone's doing it
all right we got we got too many super
chats we got way too many
western canadian commentary says i get
12 hour suspension twice daily with no
noticeable effect thank you for all the
for uh thank you all for all your work
it was tim castaire that inspired me to
move to the country a month ago we have
five veggies growing and i get to clean
up our chicken coop tomorrow isn't it so
much fun
when uh kim she's our chicken tender
goes out
and sorry chicken tender made me laugh
yeah well the best thing was
when my brother was was running it
his his name is chris poole so he was
chris p chicken tender chris oh wow
amazing but it's really i i you know
it's so much fun watching chicken city
when kim goes in because they chase her
around
because she's got food loves them the
chickens are like
this food's coming like you have to see
she is their god
it's like
some kind of giant creature walking
around with a bucket full of
cheeseburgers handing them out to people
people are like oh give me one one
that's so weird right
cheeseburgers
all right aimt 2020 says elsa gates
sounds very similar to momo on youtube
kids momo would threaten kids into
turning on the stove and other dangerous
things around the house what that sounds
like a horror movie wow
yo that's crazy
yeah that was creepy
john galt says cat gone ian rejoins the
conversation oh i had to dig him out
from underneath that chair over there
when he gets in a little hovel he he
wants to play like that oh and he's got
sharpie yeah nails so i gotta lift up
the chair and kind of
coax them out michael mammoth says tim
would you host my full-length digital
comics behind your paywall michael
mammoth for a 25 at michael mammoth for
a 25-page issue let me write that down
because the answer is yes if your comic
is good
i am writing down your name
and um we talked about a long time ago
the goal will ultimately be to have like
everything i would love to do like
weekly manga releases or graphic novel
releases you call manga we're not
japanese but something like that because
i'm a big fan of shonen jump for like 10
years i read every wednesday naruto scan
lations i wonder if george alexopoulos
would do
uh exclusive behind the paywall stuff
we'll reach out to him george alex
opolis is my favorite artist he's so
good it is the most brilliant stuff ever
we have his paintings up
this the probably the best thing i've
ever seen was when he he drew the trade
towers
and it says society and democracy on it
as a trucker that says free speech
flying into it with a clan hood is
amazing that one wasn't in the clandog
but the one where he made the truckers
with the giant trucks having clan hoods
on them he was mocking the new yorker or
something like that how they like their
style of comics it was just
g prime85 on twitter instagram you got
to follow george he's a he's brilliant
he's a genius
so uh yes michael we will i'll take a
look
all right
michael also oh i'm sorry that was
michael agusto says 10 to 12 000 years
ago we rebelled against the anunnaki ets
and they want to enslave us again easier
if we are weak and depopulated
yes
i don't think so but okay
huh they did have flying machines though
yeah didn't they want us to mine gold
for them for their atmosphere because
their atmosphere is elliptical and so
they need to keep the planet warm using
gold particles
i see i have no idea i read the internet
sometimes
dave says i've never had a twitter
account now i want to sign up so i can
scream groomer into the void and have
the host of bots that make up twitter
banned me
yep that's about right
all right
we'll grab some more super chats
what is this what is this
christopher marr says i have an idea
let's print more money well desantis is
even doing it too he announced he's
going to give stimulus to people because
of inflation i'm like oh yeah that's
that's going to work
okay
this is why you got to vote for trump i
guess
and we'll see though it's an attorney
it's until 2024. but trump's saying he's
gonna fire everybody that's that's you
know that's great
craig shirt says we need the timcast
speak your mind tour provide a safe
place for people to speak
we are planning on for one opening up
our own venue which would have smaller
local events we would do like maybe one
or two a month tim cast irl live friday
night
where it'll be at a venue but it'll also
still be live on youtube and all that
but we're also actually setting up some
events we're looking at like miami
nashville and austin i think to do
the plan right now
is we are going to do a friday night irl
live which will be i think five hours
long
so
excellent very hard work for all of the
tim cast crew and then the speakers for
the event actually just come in and join
the podcast and then get up and leave
like every hour
so we would have like i think four or
five guests
we would sit here the whole time granted
i think honestly i'd be the only one
sitting here the entire time because
obviously we could have people come in
if lydia needed a break and people i was
gonna go to the bathroom and stuff like
that
me i'm i would just sit there and you
know
oh you got me the whole time yeah i
think we were trained the best part
though is i'm thinking about how we're
gonna do the blocking for the table so
like everyone will be sitting on one
side of the table it'll be the weirdest
thing ever any levels maybe we can have
people above above like a riser 40
chests or we just do a table that's like
an octagon
oh yeah that could work yeah
and so people can see you know this big
octagonal or something oh we could do it
in the round you ever do theater in the
round where the the stage is in the
middle and then people surround the
problem is you will see some people's
backs yeah and you see everybody else's
fronts but we'll figure it out it'll be
really really cool and then um
we'd have a
you know q and a from the audience and
stuff would be a whole lot of fun a
whole lot of fun and if we're looking at
like we're looking at cities that have a
lot of prominent individuals you know
like nashville and austin it's kind of
obvious who we'd reach out to if we did
something like that and have them on the
show it'd be really great
speak your mind tour
we've talked about doing a tour where we
actually book in like every major city
the problem is
not possible
just
completely impossible to run a business
while traveling and so i've had one
company say we will get you a private
plane every friday after your morning
show to fly out to the city when the
show's ready to go and i was like
still really hard work
but maybe
i just we don't we don't have the
ability to do that we just send a deal
with someone i don't want to do
all right
stephen buck buckev says drex had a
great interview with the furry turns out
they dress up because the anonymity
provided by costumes allows them to do
the most heinous and debaucherous acts
while dissociating themselves from those
acts
yeah see the thing is
i've actually talked to some furries and
the point is
the most innocent version of it as i've
been told is it's a personal identity
escapism that you're something else
you're someone else and you you have an
affinity for
the costume or whatever and then i've
heard that that people do debaucherous
things but i don't that's that's i've
been told that's not like the core of it
the corvette is more of an identity
thing
okay rel says trump stopped funding the
world health organization buying
reinstated funding ccp connection
yeah i certainly think so
shane mann says hey zubie being from the
uk what's your favorite band from your
homeland i can name so many great bands
from the 60s 70s from the uk
interested in hearing what you were
raised on thanks
man i'm not that much of a band person
i'm more of a hip-hop and rap person
so
i don't know if i have a favorite
british band to be totally honest
british band yeah i don't really have an
answer there's tons of them it's just
not really my main genre what about
british hip-hop
british hip-hop um
what's that called grime
grime is a sub-genre okay sub-genre of
hip-hop really um i like a lot of
british rappers um
i like stormzy jme skepta getz
uh my friend shaldo is really dope
um ooh
who else am i
into right man there's there's a lot
those are the ones that come off come to
my head right off the top but i feel
like i'm missing out some major ones but
there's a lot of there's a lot of dope
british hip-hop and grime now right on
all right evil empire cigar society says
i have a cigar show interviewing brand
owners in the industry with people like
the daily wirecast and crowder that
enjoy them would you consider doing some
content with us let's build that content
arc i don't smoke so perhaps i don't
know what we would do
cigars are all right you just puff on
them for the taste don't inhale
jay everett says alex jones is right
save alex jones yeah i think they're
doing jury selection they announced that
today or something
hopefully going to court oh the gut is
company
man
eraftis of stet says there is a phrase
in my church the wise man builds his
house on the rock that's right you need
to anchor yourself to something in order
to be able to adapt
oh very nice very nice
chris b says ian's anti-christian
rhetoric is becoming very grating i saw
that super chat actually but the thing
was i'd never mentioned christianity
today i i did say at one point don't
think that god is going to save you but
that if you think that means
christianity then that's your echo
chamber i don't i just don't know i'm
talking about the monolith
i think someone someone mary mentioned
christianity in response to that but i'm
just talking about we're talking about
the faith that
this country has
had up until very recently it is
christianity so that's what i assumed
you were
i'm flying i'm talking about the world
and people having a belief that
something external will save them and i
i want to inspire people to save
themselves
all right
gla fonda says zooby based brother in
arms
the decadent rot in the west has a
spiritual component to it
is the transhumanist agenda known as the
great reset a mass ritual sacrifice to
save the earth or to serve a more
fiendish master
uh look i i don't i don't know exactly
why
certain things are happening um
that that's a huge question that's a
whole
i i i don't know i don't know the why
the why is
a confusing part but as i said i think
when you're dealing with
actual evil when you're dealing with
genuine malice if you are a
decent non-malicious non-evil person it
can be
really hard to understand the motive the
same goes this is why it's so hard on
you can't understand serial killers and
stuff right like you're not meant to be
able to understand it because you just
don't even operate it was really afraid
like like aoc faking being in handcuffs
it's freaking weird faking it yeah just
to manipulate people yeah very weird
isn't it yep and then later she was like
it's because it's the safest thing to do
so you don't get charged with resisting
it's like lady you're a sitting member
of congress at a sit-in being carried
away to a vip gathering area where
you're gonna stand and fist pump with a
bunch of other members of congress and
her friends did the same as well they
also pretended
i could see though if she was flailing
her arms around as she was walking like
this then if someone mimicked her and
did it and got hurt
then that would be a problem she would
be responsible
because people are going to watch her be
like i want to be like
her arms around she's just walking in
yeah she was like out if her arms were
out when she was under arrest that might
be a problem for someone that wasn't
there come on she is just acting yeah
she's just acting it's malicious evil it
is it is it is nihilism and it's pure
it's millennial nihilism too it's this
you know nothing matters but power
that's david graber said it before he
passed said the left has a has embraced
the fascistic tenet there is no truth
but power
and that's exactly what they've been
following what they've been pursuing
back to their roots
the wild animals
and then people who get power just cause
everyone to suffer and extract until
finally they can't extract anything else
i was thinking a day like a government
can just take your company turn it to
zero and seize everything if they want
through force like what is there other
than force not even force they can
literally just
un like they can just dissolve it
dissolve your filing yeah but then if
you're like well i'm still going to sell
my goods they'll send
feds or whatever to the house and be
like no you're going to come with us i
mean i guess there is some element of
truth to the fact that everything in the
i mean one could argue that everything
in the world that exists is ultimately
at the end point backed up by
violence or the threat of it
right here we got one here seems like it
douglas todd says brain implants will
become necessary due to competition how
can someone without the implants compete
with those that have them exactly
tattoos you can have non-invasive
graphene tattoos imagine not having a
cell phone
how would you get a job they'll be like
you want to work here yes what's your
phone number i don't have one well how
do i get in touch with you send me a
letter i'll be like okay no that's not
gonna happen it's like okay sure i'll
send you a letter that guy's got a cell
phone i'll text him instead okay i only
have a landline phone i don't have a
cell phone so you can call me okay well
what if you're what if there's an
emergency and we need to get in touch
with you for some reason oh i don't know
okay well if i hire that guy's got a
cell phone and if a key goes missing or
something i can just text him yeah i'm
not gonna hire the guy without a cell
phone that's someone's gonna have a
brain implant and they're gonna be like
oh if anything happens just interface
with me and i'll give you all the info
well i say okay i say tattoo because
eventually we'll be having like
removable tattoos on the back of our
neck that can do the same thing the
implant can do so you won't need
anything
but how is that graphene electromagnetic
well like they can just check them out
uh yeah it's like a sticker maybe like a
they call it a tattoo but you can remove
it the amish make more and more sense to
me like yeah passing every passing week
yeah
i used to think they were kind of weird
now i'm like they're there you said
buttons were too far
i'm like they're onto something there
yeah yeah there we go a graphing tattoo
to continuously monitor your brain waves
but people people don't understand amish
don't really live completely just like
without i don't know i know it's not
literally i know it's not literally
nothing there's like um if you go along
the east coast there's like a
supermarket run by the amish and there's
like
ice cream machines and
grills like but they're dressed like you
know how much people and they make food
and you eat it i assume there's
different degree there's there's varying
degrees just like they're over there i
think we just got to ask someone who's
amish to like hey explain that because i
remember in chicago as a farmer's market
and like a trucks that like amish farms
pulls up and they're like amish people
driving in the car pulling up to sell
their food or whatever
they'll do it if it involves making
money yeah i think
i think people completely exaggerate a
lot of what homage people do
but i do think it's for the most part
probably true they're chilling minding
their own business yeah
honeybadger says had a debate with a
friend about your civil war theory and
he pointed out states suing another
state idk the court working on state
courts and my issue is what if the feds
say we're not getting involved so the
scenario represented is
uh colorado has no restriction on
abortion texas bans abortion men and
women have kid or get pregnant
at eight months then says you know what
i don't want the kid i'm going to kill
it flees to colorado the husband says no
no she's taking my my son he's viable
she's going to kill him colorado has no
limit federal government says we got
nothing to do with this
what happens people need to stop being
demons
like stop being demonic like if you're
eight months pregnant and you've got a
man like like what are you doing but
right right just stop sure but like
we shouldn't be having needing to have
these conversations the scenario there
is does the dad just say guess she'll
kill my kid or does he go come on guys
round up the gang and we're getting in
the truck and going to save my kid
um i think the latter is quite likely
or or what if the texas then says we no
longer allow interstate commerce with
colorado because of the kidnapping of
one of our residents for execution or
something i i don't know man uh yeah
when you let's say like stop being
demons i think of it as like it's
impossible to to go against the
avalanche i mean it's not impossible
it's very hard so what do you propose to
i think there's two i think there's too
much black peeling going on man honestly
i don't think it's i don't think it's
healthy
when did you start working out when i
was 15
yeah um
no man
sorry i feel i feel like that there was
some what was it you said just before
that how to give people hope how to get
them because tell them to stop being
black though it's different than giving
them the white people yeah of course man
no i mean i all i push is optimism man
why do why do i do what i do online and
uh you know with my books and podcasts
and everything i mean
i i i think that we need to be careful
um
when we're being you know realistic like
i i don't i i'm not saying
stick your head in the sand and act like
there's nothing wrong i talk about
plenty of things that are wrong in the
world and so on but i think that
these things can become self-fulfilling
prophecies i think if you think that oh
my gosh like whoever you think are the
evil elites or globalists or you know
people who want to just run things and
enslave humanity i think if the
narrative is pushed that
this is just inevitable and it's going
to happen and it's hopeless and there's
nothing you can do do with it about it i
think it becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy because demoralization is
incredibly powerful i mean if you if you
want to completely crush an enemy then
you demoralize them to the point where
they don't even fight because they don't
think that they can or they join you or
they join you exactly let's grab one
more super chat from techru he says come
on man furry hate again libertarian and
conservative furries think you're
awesome we smash the like button and
even subscribe with cash money there are
weird weirdos in every genre i'll go on
the show i mean no i agree with that
i've been saying that because we've had
a bunch of people who are like dude
i literally don't care what people do
when they're engaging in their own
personal
you know life choices or styles or
whatever i learned to the less when i
was a kid and i told the story before
that when we started skating it was the
cool thing was to wear skin tight jeans
the older guys in their 20s wore really
big baggy jeans and they made fun of us
and we laughed at them for being old and
out of touch
then when i got older the younger kids
started wearing dickies that went down
to their ankles like floods and then all
the people that like were my age started
making fun of him being like look at
those idiots wearing flooded pants and i
was like bro you're saying exactly what
that dude said about you for wearing
tight jeans yeah and he was like well
yeah i know but tight jeans are cool and
those are dumb and i'm like no dude
you're dumb
and then like i just started wearing
regular jeans because i'm like everybody
just do whatever you want man just don't
hate people you know yeah all right man
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show and head over to
timcast.com we're gonna have the
uncensored after hours show coming up at
about 11 p.m tonight you can follow the
show at tim cast irl you can follow me
personally everywhere at tim cast zubi
do you have anything to shout out yeah
sure you can follow me at zooby music
that is zuby music and go to
teamzubi.com if you want to check out my
music merchandise everything else and my
children's book the candy calamity is
out now with brave books and you can get
that at candycalamity.com
if you want to see me again you can find
me on instagram or wechat at closer
kitty and i also demand that you go
subscribe to pop culture crisis on
youtube we go live at 3 p.m eastern noon
pacific time every monday through friday
go check it out and at timcast.com soon
it'll be on the homepage yes you guys
can follow me at ian crossland.net i
want to shout out everyone in the chat
that's that's got the zoo taking the
zooby pill we got justin henry
neo mix with the z pill that's what it's
all about dudes um thanks for coming man
thanks for making the book too that's
super cool no doubt and one special
shout out to tim's big beautiful
rooster that's up in uh
up in but i was gonna say central park
but maybe we can do that at some point
times square wanted to just get a 96
foot billboard of mike
roberta jr you did good man i'm proud of
you buddy
well speaking of the black pill and the
white pill and the zooby pill i do have
to say that zooby's twitter is actually
an excellent source of positivity one of
the only ones that i have found to be
consistently uplifting on twitter so i
feel like he's single-handedly making
the platform into something good which
is very encouraging to see so thank you
for doing that thank you for coming on
the show tonight thank you guys all for
joining us tonight yes go follow pop
culture crisis uh politics is downstream
of culture we know that for sure you
guys can follow me on twitterminds.com
at sourpatchlids as well as
sourpatchlist.net
we will see all of you at timcast.com
and the uncensored after show and thanks
for hanging out bye guys
you